one of the surprising things about
network speed is that a lot of what
determines the end-to-end speed of a
network in practice is not the
throughput how fast you can push bits
through the channel but the latency the
time it takes to get a response from the
other end let's take a look at where
that latency comes from
for each http request even after we've
gotten the radio to wake up we have to
do a dns lookup to figure out what that
domain name server actually means in
terms of ip number
we have to make a socket connection to
that site we have to actually send the
http request and then we actually get
our data back each one of these steps
takes time
on an lte network each one of these
requests takes between 240 and 500
milliseconds depending on whether we
already have a connection going or not
on 3g
each request will take 600 milliseconds
to 3.5 seconds that's per every http
request